next one we got over here is pick up
heavy [__] put it down straight [__]
forward guys there's absolutely no
excuse in today's world for you being
fat lazy out of shape shaped like a pair
any of those things
um if you think it's acceptable
unsubscribe don't watch my [__] leave
honestly I've I have no respect for
anybody that doesn't live in a strong
body you can't have a strong successful
mind without a strong successful looking
body the two things are aligned and they
Go and Tow if you improve your body your
mind will improve if you improve your
mind your body should improve as well
you know be total along the way do it
it's like there's no question about it
and beyond that I'm going to say Combat
Sports and once you got into Combat
Sports test yourself get into a fight
I'm not talking like a street fight but
I'm talking about you know if you've
gotten into whatever boxing kickboxing
you know whatever it happens to be once
you've gone through
um you know all the years of work and
your coach feels like you've got the
skills test yourself do the work do the
work in your body do the work in your
mind do the work in your bad skills do
the damn work
yeah totally agreed
um you know my my weight in physique is
something I struggle with for a very
long time and it's something that up
until recently has been just something
I've really been trying to dial in so
um there's been some changes to my
endocrine system there's been some
things that I'm working on trying to get
you know locked in and
um I was you know competitive and I'm a
huge number Chaser at the gym I like I
like being strong like throwing around
heavy weights a lot of fun
um but not at the risk of you know your
health so you know if you're one of
these guys that wants to be just one of
these big bulking behemoths it's hey
it's not going to be healthy for you
overall you know 300 pounds or 300
pounds no matter if it's muscle or fat
um and two you know if you understand
generally what women find attractive so
as far as the V taper goes if there's
your guys think they have to be a lot
more muscular and a lot more bulky than
they really do to get kind of the
attention they want you're about you're
going to get more attention from guys
actually than you are from Girls so
yeah I mean you know she just basically
wants to look at you and see a V taper
and there's nothing more to it than just
that
um next one after that was optimizing
the endocrine system as you age and um
again there's a chapter in my book
I get into detail on that and I'm
revising that chapter to include some
updates that I've learned along the way
um I really need to do an entire
unplugged Alpha podcast on everything
that I do to optimize
um my self-care and slow down minimize
aging uh because at my stage of the game
like most guys my age are nowhere near
as copper number as capable as I am
um but there's some work that's involved
and I think like starting with managing
your endocrine system and that's as
simple as if you're 25 30 27 doesn't
matter if you're under the age of 30
start there by at least once a year
tracking your hormone panel I'm not
talking about just tracking testosterone
get a full hormone panel done go to the
doctor and tell them you want to run
blood Labs you want to know your
estrogen your free testosterone your
bioavailable testosterone whatever it is
they're going to call it where you're at
your total testosterone DHEA
DHT uh you want to get your lipid
profile you want to check your liver
enzymes you want to check your kidneys
you want to check everything and make
sure that you're on top of your lab is
because if you don't by the time you
realize there's a problem it's usually
too late you're probably in you know
some stage of uh chronic kidney failure
whether it's early stages or mid-stage
you might have elevated liver enzymes
that you haven't been tracking
just just trust me on this like the the
simple thing one is you know read the
chapter in the book so you get some get
some further Clarity but two just check
your blood Labs right do it just on an
annual basis it's probably going to cost
you a couple bucks but figure out how
your body operate operates so as you get
older and it starts to change its
behavior and and your panels change you
have some sort of Baseline of what your
body acted like in an optimal fashion
when you were younger because you can
throw anything at your body in your 20s
like honestly
dude I'm like like you're getting closer
into your 30s now right but when I was
in my 20s it was like you could get up
smash back a protein shake or an
omelette bag of Doritos smoke a joint go
to the gym you know do nothing all day
and get up in the morning and look
jacked and ripped right like your body
has a way of metabolizing it's very very
efficient but as you get older it's not
as efficient and you have to be way more
attentive with everything you put into
it whether it's hormones whether it's
nutraceuticals what you eat how you
train when you train all that stuff I'll
do a a full in-depth video you guys let
me know if that's something that you
want in the comments below and I'll make
sure that I make that happen to get into
everything that I've uh that I've been
doing you got anything else on top of
that
I just for the first time got them got
them done and I've made some changes so
um you know don't wait until the
symptoms are really a pain in your ass
to to go get them looked at because it's
it's it's a hard life man it's when your
your body's not firing on all cylinders
like it should be and there's a way to
optimize it um
it's something that should take priority
your health is health is number one
um you know because the estrogen in our
system in our society is only increasing
so I mean our average testosterone as a
man goes down every single decade every
single generation so
um you know even in your 20s you might
think that oh like okay I I don't even
have to think about trt until I'm 40 or
I don't have to get my loves our blood
labs done until I'm at least 30. you
never know what you're going to find and
you never know what might need to be you
know tweaked uh and and could be
possibly improved and give you
um you know a higher quality of life for
a number of years yeah
never allow the state to decide was the
next one after that I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out